we would to welcome everyone this
evening to
our latest installment of
provisions
for the great meeting for the day
of the great appointment the day of
resurrection
authored by sheikh
islam shem sadin
i'd to congratulate everyone that
is joining us this evening
on the live live feed
congratulations that allah subhanahu wa
allah has chosen you
or even if you are watching this at a
later time
that allah subhanahu wa has chosen that
you hear these words and hear this part
of the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's legacy
it's a great honor that allah choose
your hearing
and your heart to contain this
we'd to mention something before we
begin
and that is the issue of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
choosing a place for his revelation
to reside what does that mean
had responded to the mushrikeen
the polytheists in surat al-anam
when they had said
that when the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam came to
the people of mecca and the idolaters
therein with the message of allah with
divine revelation
that when he came when he came to them
and delivered this revelation
one of their responses and one of their
very
absurd responses
was we will not believe until we are
given ex
the way that given revelation in the
same way that
all the other messengers were given
revelation
meaning that each and every one of us
should have the angel
come to him and give him the
revelation personally
we shouldn't have to take it through the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and so allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
responded to this and
rebuked them and said
knows best where to place his messages
where to place his divine revelations
what does that mean that means that he
subhanahu ta'ala chose the heart
of the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
as a place for the
for his revelations to reside this is a
very
great honor from allah
likewise those companions and the
scholars of islam
that came after and the muslims at large
varying based on their different levels
with allah
some have been given much and some have
been given less
but each muslim
has been chosen by allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
for at least a portion of his divine
revelation to reside
that is a great honor from allah
if allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chooses
your heart
as one of the vessels to contain any of
his revelation
even if it is only one verse that
is one of the most grand
honors that any human being could aspire
to
and we're speaking of course about the
heart we're not speaking about
merely hearing abu jahl abu lahab
all of these people the hypocrites the
munafikun
they all heard the revelations of allah
subhanallah they heard the quran
we're not speaking about just hearing it
we're speaking about the quran
residing in your heart
as allah said to the prophet muhammad
and he mentions that
was sent down by allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
was sent down by allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
upon the heart of the messenger of allah
and allah said about the quran
that it is the quran the revelations his
verses
are clear and explicit verses of
guidance
in the chess of those whom allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has granted
understanding and knowledge
we're not speaking about just hearing it
we're not speaking about just
memorizing it there are hypocrites
that will memorize much of the quran
all of the quran even right
and it's been narrated that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the thing i fear most over my nation
is a hypocrite with a learned tongue
a hypocrite who is proficient
in the knowledge of the quran and sunnah
this is different this person knows the
quran and sunnah's wordings
and knows the facts on a superficial
level it's only
up here it has not gone down into their
chest
into their hearts where faith and eman
resides
we're not speaking about being chosen
for that
we are speaking about being chosen by
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
for your heart and your soul
to be touched by allah
to be touched by the revelations of
allah
subhanahu wa this
is what we are referring to
if this is the case that is a great
honor
and you have been given a portion of
what the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was given
[Silence]
sorry about that we're having just some
little technical difficulties
i will continue and so if your heart is
chosen by allah for
any of his verses to reside
that is a blessing that is innumerable
it is invaluable
and
mentions in
one of his books called al-fawed
is one of the books where he wrote it's
kind of a journal of reflections
it's just a random book compiled of many
different things he might
think of something one day and just jot
it down right
it has many many different
essays and little nuggets of wisdom et
cetera it's called al-fawaii
the book of benefits or the book of gems
or pearls
and one of the chapters of this book
allah says that the name of this chapter
he named it
the similarities between the heart
of the human being and the throne of
allah
subhanahu the similarities between the
heart of the human being
and the throne of allah and he mentions
that
just as the throne of allah is the
literal
place or the literal creation of allah
upon which he rose
likewise the heart of the human being is
the
metaphorical place or throne
upon which the knowledge and names and
attributes of allah rose upon
and just as the throne of allah had to
be the most
pure to be
befitting for allah to rise above it
likewise the heart of the human being
has to be most pure in order for the
names and attributes and knowledge of
allah to rise above it
and so allah chooses these hearts
he is the one who chooses the hearts
vessels and distinguishes how much
each of this these hearts shall contain
of his knowledge and his wisdom and his
names and attributes
and understanding of his ways
subhanahu wata'ala
this is something which is a great honor
from allah and so if your heart has been
chosen
from amongst these hearts to carry any
of the
verses of allah the names the attributes
of allah to have understood it
for it you have touched you in the core
of your heart
and the depths of your soul for it to be
carried therein
then allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
chosen that and that is a great gift
that must be
shielded and guarded and respected and
thanked
in the chapter regarding the day of
jumu'
he mentions the day of jumu'
and he mentions the virtues or some of
the virtues of the day of jumu'
and he mentions a few narrations with
regards to
the virtues of the day of jumu' one of
these
being the ijaba or stijeva
the time in which allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
will accept the dua
except the supplication of anyone who
supplicates him
on that day at that time
this is called ijaba this is the time
of acceptance of dua
of answering
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
said about the day of jumu'
he said
he said the day of jumu' of its
many virtues is that there is a
a time during that day
in which no muslim will be
in prayer asking allah for
anything during that time except that
allah will give it to him
and grant him what he asks now when is
this the scholars of islam differ
on when this time of ijaba is
some of the scholars of islam mentioned
that this is
this is when the khatib
or the imam is giving the khutbah
that it is from when the imam begins the
khutba
until he is finished with salah that is
the opinion of abdullah
others mentioned that it is the final
hour of the day of jumu'
meaning after asur just before maghrib
this is taken from a narration collected
by imam and nasa'i and others
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
has 12 hours what does that mean
has 12 hours what's meant by
hours here is 12
12 units of time that's what's meant
by an
hour in the arabic language when
we use the word
we use it colloquially we use it in our
modern
arabic to mean one hour 60 minutes but
this is not what was meant
by asa in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
simply because they did not do
time in that way they did not have
watches an hour was not 60 minutes
a minute was not 60 seconds etc this is
not how
they kept time this is before the
invention of watches
yet the prophet sallallahu alaihi was
said
that on the day of jumu' it is 12
hours long meaning 12 units of time long
the scholars of islam say that what is
meant by the day of jumu'
is from the break of dawn until dusk
until the sun
sets if we take that amount of time
whether it's 8 hours
or 17 hours or 16 hours or 18 hours in
certain parts
and we divide that into 12 parts
each one of those 12 parts is what is
meant by the
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was referring to
and in sunnah it's mentioned that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that the time
when allah will answer the dua
is the last and the twelfth hour
of those final hours so that would be
when
just before salat al-maghrib after salah
just
that this is the time when allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will answer
the dua a person may then ask
well isn't it impermissible to be
praying during that time
i mean the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam
prohibited that a person makes salah
after also until the sun has set
or as some of the companions narrated
as the sun is setting
so how can we harmonize between that
narration
and this narration which encourages
prayer during that time
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
was identifies the time of
the acceptance of dua
on the day of jumu' as being the final
hour just before
sir
and that a person is in prayer asking
allah for something
he mentions that
one of the interpretations of this is
that what is meant by prayer
is that a person remains in the masjid
after making sure
why because the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that a person is
in salah as long as he is waiting for
salah
and that a person is in salah
as long as he remains in his place where
he prayed
without breaking his wudu or harming
anyone the person is still in salah
a person is in salah when he's headed to
the masjid
he's in salah when he's in the masjid
waiting for prayer to start
he's obviously in salah while he's
physically praying in the way that we
all know
he's in salah as long as he remains
seated or remains in the masjid where he
prayed as long as he doesn't break his
wadu
or harm anyone and he is furthermore
in salah on his way back home
as long as he doesn't break his wadu
so some of the scholars of islam
mentioned that what is intended by
prayer here assalah
is that a person is in salah
meaning in any of these positions
either on his way to prayer to the
masjid to pray
or he is waiting for salat al-masjid
or he is in prayer because he reached
the masjid and let's say he made
tahiyat al-masjid to raqqa or he made
two raqqa for
the or he made two raqqa for
a taharah meaning that he made wudu and
he makes two raka
or any of the other reasons or that a
person
is has praised
in the masjid and remained in the masjid
until merib
this person is still in salah in any of
these situations
and so this is the most correct opinion
as to when this time of hijab is what is
the point
of all of this the point is to
articulate
the immense virtue that is
found in the day of jumu'
the immense virtue that is found on the
day of jumu'
that it is a blessed day which is the
most virtuous of
all of the days of the week and that
during this time
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has very
specific
things that he looks for in the human
being
and there is very specific and immense
magnified reward that is
disseminated upon the people on the day
of jummah for those who are
asking
then mentions when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam first arrived
to medina as we mentioned this
book is the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's biography
intertwined with the
rulings of phil right
he says that the messenger of allah
arrived
at medina and he first arrived at
quebec and he resided in quebec
on monday tuesday
wednesday and thursday
so
and then after having established
the masjid of quebec on the day of
thursday he left on the day of jumu'
to head towards where his masjid is
currently located
in
and then the first jummah that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam held and prayed
in medina was
in a small masjid
that was in the
tribe of beni salem and auf
he prayed there in a small masjid which
is
in the heart of the valley and this is
all before he had established his
masjid so the first jummah that the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam prayed
in medina was in
the or in the village
where the tribe of salim ibn auf resided
benny salim and he made sj
he is most known
for his
biography of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
is hap
is a narrator of hadith
he's a very well-known narrator of
hadith
who is
trustworthy and his hadith is sahih
madam
[Silence]
wrote the most lengthy and in-depth
biography
that has ever been written about the
prophet salallahu's life and times
but what happened is his biography was
lost
his biography was lost
the only thing that remains of ibn is
haqq's biography
is what was summarized by ibn heshem
even hesham many of us have heard seerat
ibn hishem
the biography of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
upon the authority of ibn hashem
this biography is
summarized from ibn ishaq
but he doesn't actually have
even his house complete work even hashem
came he summarized it and he narrated it
to us
and this is what is known as seeratibin
hisham now
even as happ said
so
evan is happy mentions and again ibn is
half is a historian
who specializes in the biography of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
he is an authority most notably
in the field of seerah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
even as haqq says
that the first khutbah that the prophet
salallahu
that was given in the masjid
of the tribe of beni salim bin auf
he then mentions a narration on the
authority
and many of us have never heard of him
but every single one of us has
been affected by abuse
how is that
meaning very few of us this is
interesting very few of us
know who abu salama even abdul rahman
is very few of us know who he is
yeah what is interesting is that every
one of us
has come across his works
what am i referring to that every is ned
every chain of narration of the quran
which roots back to the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam goes through abuse
he is one of the great narrators of the
quran
says
[Silence]
this is an amazing narration here
ebeneze hack narrates to us
that says
and we've heard
is not a companion but when he says the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said where did he get
this statement
i mean he didn't get it from him his own
mind he didn't get it from himself
obviously he had gotten this statement
from someone who heard it from the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam now his teachers those
whom
abu salam narrated from
what percentage of them are companions
probably
about 95 percent
are companions and so because of this
many of the scholars of hadith accept
the narrations of
abu salem
in that first khutbah which he gave at
the village
of beni salim
at that little masjid in the heart of
the valley of beni
salim his first khutbah
listen to this was narrated to have been
the following
it's narrated that he stood
to give the khutbah he praised the law
he said alhamdulillah
and he glorified allah and mentioned his
various names and attributes
and then the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam proceeded
and now i want you to hear this is the
entire khutbah
he said ask for what follows
o people put forth good deeds for
yourselves
do you all not know and i swear by allah
that you will all be shocked
you will all be shocked meaning by thee
by the sound of the horn that will
establish a sur
that will begin and commence the day of
resurrection
and that each one of you upon hearing
this
first blow into the horn that will
shock that you will
neglect your livestock upon that
meaning all of the things of this world
you will neglect
because obviously you will see that
there is a much more important and
worthy matter
of your attention and each of your
livestock and heard will be left without
a shepherd and each one of you
i swear by allah his lord will say to
him
without an intermediary between them
without a translator between he or his
lord
nor will there be any veil between
yourselves and your lord when he speaks
to each and every one of you on this day
he will say to one of you or to each of
us
did my messenger not come to you
and did he not convey my message to you
did i not give you wealth and did i not
bestow upon you blessings and virtues
and so what in return this is allah
speaking to each one of us
and so what in return have you done to
thank me what have you put forth with
me for yourself on this day
an individual upon such an
interaction with allah will look to his
right and look to his left
and he will not see anything worthy of
mention meaning of deeds
and then he will look forward and all he
can see
and visualize in front of him is the
fire of
hell the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam then said
whomever of you is able to protect his
own
face from the fire of hell even with
only a half of a date that you are
giving in charity
then do so
and whoever is unable to even
give they are so poor that they are
unable to give
not even a half of a date
in charity then at least
he is to strive to guard and shield his
face from the fire
or she with a good word
a good statement a statement of
positivity
something that will bring about the
pleasure of allah
he says because even a single good deed
or a single good statement of the
pleasure of allah
will be rewarded with at least ten times
at least tenfold up to 700
times he said and
after that he concluded with assalamu
alaikum
that was his entire
that was the entirety of his khutbah
meaning for the first khutbah of course
we know that salat al-jumu' has two
khotwas
but this shows the the brevity
of khutbah on the day of jumu' and how
it is
we will continue next week inshaallah
and finish up the remainder of his
khutbah
discussing more of the akam of
and this is enough for tonight
allah
[Silence]
you